J.J. Abrams spent months putting the finishing
touches on Star Wars: The Force Awakens and
didn’t lock down the final picture until
November.
During post-production, he had to sort through
hours of footage in order to deliver a film
that would please the fans.
As you might expect, a lot of stuff was left
on the cutting room floor.
Here are 10 Star Wars The Force Awakens Scenes
You've Never Seen.
SPOILER ALERT!
Stop watching now if you haven’t seen The
Force Awakens!
A Lightsaber in Space
For a while, it was rumored that the opening
shot of The Force Awakens would be the disembodied
hand of Luke Skywalker, clenching his blue
lightsaber floating through space towards
a planet.
That shot was actually in the script and was
meant to be the first image following the
text crawl before the opening sequence on
Jakku.
The scene was cut late in the game, most likely
because the lightsaber was headed towards
Takodana, and NOT Jakku.
It essentially is not related to the main
action of the first scene, so its inclusion
didn’t make a whole lot of sense anyway.
Constable Zuvio
New character Constable Zuvio lives on the
planet Jakku and tries to keep peace and order
in Niima Outpost.
He was featured in some marketing materials,
and even got his own action figure.
But he’s missing from the final film.
That’s because his one scene was cut.
He was supposed to come to Rey’s aid when
Unkar Plutt’s thugs attack her to snag BB-8,
“breaking up the tussle” and settling
the issue with the scavenger.
Instead, it’s Finn who encounters Rey during
her fight with the thugs, setting the movie’s
plot in motion.
The film probably flowed better that way.
Maz Kanata Uses the Force
Based on her dialogue from the trailers, many
fans assumed that Maz Kanata would be some
kind of Force user and help the young protagonists
tap into their potential.
While she does believe in the Force, Maz is
never shown actually using it.
But in a different cut of the film, she revealed
herself as a secret Jedi.
When the First Order attacks her castle on
Takodana, she uses the Force to make the ceiling
collapse on a group of unsuspecting stormtroopers.
The bit even got Han Solo involved, as he
had to stall the soldiers so Maz could concentrate.
This would have been a fun little moment in
a film full of them.
Unkar Plutt on Takodana
Fans learn that Rey and Finn steal the Millennium
Falcon from Unkar Plutt in their escape from
Jakku, and the junk dealer is none too pleased
about that.
He tracks them down and finds them at Maz’s
castle and confronts Rey in an attempt to
get it back.
Chewbacca comes to defend Rey, and after Plutt
makes a joke about Chewie’s arm injury,
the Wookie literally rips Plutt’s arm out
of its socket, a call back to Han’s words
of advice to C-3PO in the original film.
Star Wars is no stranger to dismembered limbs,
but this was probably too graphic even for
them, and having Plutt randomly pop up in
the second act may have slowed the pacing
down.
Maz at the Resistance Base
It was a scene millions of fans dissected
in the second teaser: Maz Kanata handing over
Luke’s old lightsaber to Leia.
But it didn’t show up in the finished film.
Abrams stated that it was cut because there
wasn’t anything for Maz to do story wise
when she arrived at the Resistance base with
the others.
The script was retooled so Maz remained on
Takodana and Finn took the lightsaber with
him when the group left the planet.
As great as Maz was it’s better she wasn’t
just standing around without a purpose during
the third act.
Kylo Ren on the Millennium Falcon
Fans learn that villain Kylo Ren is actually
Ben Solo, the son of Han Solo and Princess
Leia.
That means he probably made a few fond childhood
memories aboard the Millennium Falcon, a theory
supported by this deleted scene.
When he senses his father near on Starkiller
base, Kylo finds the Falcon outside in the
snow, and boards the ship.
He sits in the cockpit and says, “Han Solo.”
It’s a nice, quiet moment for the character
that would have been an interesting inclusion
in the film.
But it arguably slows down the rapid fire
pace, which is most likely why it was cut.
General Leia’s Intro
Leia’s official first appearance in the
film is a touching reunion with Han Solo,
but she originally was going to show up much
earlier.
In a cut sequence, she has a conversation
with Korr Sella, who Leia sends to the Galactic
Senate to ask for aid in the Resistance’s
fight against the First Order.
The scene would have cleared up one of the
more confusing elements of the movie – the
political landscape of the galaxy – and
given viewers a clearer idea of what happened
during the Starkiller base’s attack on the
Hosnian system.
Like so many deleted scenes, it was likely
removed for pacing issues.
Rey’s Extended Force Vision
When on Takodana, Rey is called to Luke’s
lightsaber and has a Force vision detailing
the past and future.
Originally, it was a bit longer.
The sequence was going to include the moment
where Vader chops off Luke’s hand in The
Empire Strikes Back, and Hasbro even produced
action figures of the two characters.
Even more intriguing was an explanation of
how the lightsaber ended up at Maz’s castle,
showing it get discovered and passed along
over the years.
In the final film, the lightsaber question
is brushed off as one saved for another day,
so hopefully fans will get the full story.
Snowspeeder Chase
The Force Awakens had plenty of action sequences,
but it could have had one more.
There was a snowspeeder chase that took place
outside the Starkiller base involving Finn,
Rey, and some First Order stormtroopers.
Vehicles from the chase were produced for
the Force Awakens toy line, and the sequence
even appears in the novelization.
While it would have been an exciting set piece,
it’s difficult to say where it would have
fit in during the finished film.
It doesn’t appear to serve the story during
the climactic third act, which would have
been the wrong way to go.
We’ll take the finales we got in the theatrical
cut.
Vader’s Sentiment
Supreme Leader Snoke is a mysterious figure,
but one thing we do know about him is his
understanding of galactic history.
He saw the rise and fall of the Empire, and
believes it was not poor strategizing that
was their downfall.
He blames Darth Vader’s love for his son,
Luke, for why the Imperials failed.
Snoke and Kylo Ren talk about that fateful
moment and how it was a “momentary lapse”
for an otherwise great man.
A key part of Kylo’s training is to detach
himself from his family attachments, leading
to his emotional confrontation with Han Solo.
How far Snoke goes with this remains to be
seen.
Those are the Force Awakens deleted scenes
we think should have made the final cut but
let us know if we missed any in the comments
below!
We hope to discover more Star Wars Secrets
very soon!
If you’re a Star Wars fan check out our
documentary on The Hidden Truth Behind Star
Wars, you’re sure to get your mind blown!
You should also check out our friends at The
Richest and their new video about mistakes
in recent movies!
Thanks again for watching and subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this one!